my contention is all kids have
tremendous talents and we squander them
pretty ruthlessly i had a great story
recently i love telling it of a little
girl who was in a drawing lesson she was
six and she was at the back drawing and
the teacher said this little girl hardly
ever paid attention and in this drawing
lesson she did and the teacher was
fascinated she went over to and she said
what are you drawing
and the girl said i'm drawing a picture
of god
and the teacher said but nobody knows
what god looks like
and the girl said they will in a minute
kids will take a chance
you know if they don't know
they'll have a go
am i right they're not frightened of
being wrong
now i don't mean to say that being wrong
is the same thing as being creative what
we do know is if you're not prepared to
be wrong you'll never come up with
anything original
if you're not prepared to be wrong
and by the time they get to be adults
most kids have lost that capacity
they have become frightened of being
wrong and we run our companies this by
the way we stigmatize mistakes
and we're now running national education
systems where mistakes are the worst
thing you can make
and the result is that we are educating
people out of their creative capacities
if you think about the whole system of
public education around the world it's a
protracted process of university
entrance
and the consequence is that many highly
talented brilliant creative people think
they're not
because the thing they were good at at
school wasn't valued or was actually
stigmatized
and i think we can't afford to go on
that way picasso once said this he said
that all children are born artists
the problem is to remain an artist as we
grow up
i believe this passionately that we
don't grow into creativity we grow out
of it
or rather we get educated at it
we have to be careful now that we use
this gift wisely and the only way we'll
do it is by seeing our creative
capacities for the richness they are
and seeing our children for the hope
that they are
and our task is to educate their whole
being so they can face this future by
the way we may not see this future
but they will
and our job is to help them make
something of it